[Music]
it's been just over six months since
russia invaded ukraine and in that time
thousands of lives have been claimed on
the battlefield and in ukrainian cities
under attack from russia
alongside this however is escalating
economic destruction
the kiev school of economics says the
war has cost ukraine over 113.5
billion dollars in damage
major industries like agriculture and
steel production has sustained massive
losses as getting exports out of the
country remains complicated
meanwhile western sanctions on russia
have sought to [ __ ] its economy to
cut off financing for the war and help
bring it to an end the kremlin has paid
a heavy price but perhaps not heavy
enough
at this stage i would like to introduce
my guests starting with nick connolly
our ukraine correspondent currently in
berlin for a few days before it's back
to the front lines
on the line we have alara solanco she is
senior advisor in beaufort bank of
finland she monitors russian economic
development and economic policy welcome
to you both
so i'd like to start with a question for
both of you
starting with you nick if you could dial
back the clock six months and adjust the
western response to russian aggression
with the knowledge that we have now what
would you change
i think definitely the ukrainian
government would have wanted sanctions
before russian boots basically hit the
ground in ukraine they were calling for
preventative sanctions on russia and we
do know now that the russians were not
expecting sanctions of a scale that
we've seen this time around they were
expecting something more similar to what
happened after the annexation crimea
which was
a lot less damaging to their economy and
a lot less wide-ranging so ukraine was
calling for those as a kind of
disincentive to russia launching
military action and obviously the
ukrainians would also have wanted more
weapons ahead of this in full-scale
invasion basically they got some
anti-tank weapons which proved very
useful but were not really able to
really prevent those russian advances in
the first few months that saw russian
troops basically getting almost to give
so the sanction should have been there
in place to act as more of a deterrent
laura turning to you what would you
change
honestly i think it's um a wee bit too
early to to provide a good analysis of
what should have been done differently
um i do agree the sanctions
against russia are unprecedented
and especially the sanctions hitting the
financial markets
have been really really
harsh
and then uh the the western response in
restricting russia's
exports has been uh somewhat more slow
and i think when thinking on the
economic
economic side of sanctions that that's
probably somewhere a place where
a bit more eu unity would be would have
been helpful to to get the decisions
made faster but
broadly i think we're
we are sort of
given the limitations of what economic
sanctions can
contain what the the eu and the west has
has been doing a pretty good job
we're going to look at some of those
russian economic numbers more in detail
but we already told you a little bit in
the beginning about the blows suffered
by the ukrainian economy but here are
some more figures the international
monetary fund has forecast a 35 drop in
ukrainian gdp this year but ukraine's
economy minister says her country's
economy could stabilize during the
coming year and grow as much as 15 and a
half percent julius feridenko said the
growth depended on military developments
in the war with russia
so nick you know there are real people
behind these numbers and you've spent a
lot of time traveling around the country
maybe you could give us a bit of a
picture about how this economic impact
looks like on the ground i mean lots of
people i know in kiev have basically not
had a full salary since the beginning of
their war i mean you know lots of
supply chains are now broken they can't
even if they can produce their normal
products they can't get it out of the
country because the reports being shut
off we've seen some progress there with
some of the food exports being allowed
out but
metals and all the other kind of normal
mainstays of ukraine's economy are still
blocked and stuck in the country and
these are products that you know it can
be shipped by land but it would be much
more expensive more difficult to do so
lots of people are now basically at the
end of their savings they might have
been able to get through the first few
months at their normal kind of level of
consumption normal level quality of life
but that definitely is ending now some
people are doing okay those tend to be
people in sectors like it who have
income coming in from abroad whose job
is basically mobile and they are able
even if they left the country or they've
had to move from their home towns
further away from the front lines
they've been able to carry on working
but it's really you know
this war has
exposed those differences and those
imbalances in term between the kind of
export-driven economy in the knowledge
economy and the it and then the people
who really are
dependent on bricks and mortar on
infrastructure on ports on those kind of
logistical supply chains that are now uh
really not working and are really having
a really devastating impact i was with
farmers a couple of weeks ago who are
trying to you know get their grain out
and they were even questioning whether
they would they'd be able to sow a new
crop of grain because they hadn't been
paid for
any of the grain they'd shipped they had
lots still left in their store storage
units and they simply didn't have the
cash to buy fertilizers to buy seeds so
this is really a crunch time now kind of
six months in where people are really
asking themselves how we're going to
keep on functioning we've been kind of
surviving for six months but
where does it go from here
what is the answer to that question
a lot of people are looking at the
government for help and there have been
certain uh programs especially for
agriculture in terms of kind of cheap
loans but you know
as far as the wider economy and you know
ukraine's almost 40 million people
basically it's up to them to survive i
mean you know ukrainians are
very
used to getting by to going abroad to
earn money in case of economic kind of
troubles back home and that's not an
option right now for men who are not
allowed to leave the country because
they might be called up to serve in the
army um there are lots of billions of
euros coming in every month from
ukrainians abroad it's one of the
biggest sources of income for the
country and that's become even more
important those remittances as the rest
of the economy has kind of fallen away
so new industries really proving to be a
lifeline here so i understand that
people are just trying to survive the
best they can but how much of a topic is
russia's economy in ukraine given that
it's also a proxy for how well-equipped
russia is to continue its aggression
well certainly there have been lots of
social media kind of interest in terms
of western companies leaving
brands like mcdonald's or you know the
sportswear brands leaving russia that's
been seen as a kind of sign that russia
is increasingly isolated and kind of on
its own facing up against kind of the
wider west in this battle i think for
now that people are kind of painfully
aware of the fact that russia is
actually making record-breaking earnings
in terms of its energy exports even
though it's maybe selling lesser volumes
because of issues with transport but
still given you know the kind of
unprecedented prices on energy right now
even if they're selling their oil and
gas at a discount to new buyers in
places like india and china they're
still bringing in
hundreds of you know billions of dollars
this year and that is something that
unfortunately for ukraine is going to
mean that russia is able to keep up the
war as it is at this current level of
intensity for months if not years to
come
now both laura and nick have already
alluded to the state of the russian
economy but it's information that bears
repeating so let's look at how for
example the ruble has fared since at the
beginning of the war when russia invaded
ukraine on february 24 one u.s dollar
could buy 80 rubles after sanctions hit
the value of the ruble plummeted on
march 14 a dollar would buy 116 rubles
yet by march 31 the currency had
recovered to pre-war levels hitting a
high in june and stabilizing the last
few weeks around the 60 rubles to one
dollar mark
now many economists predicted at the
beginning of the war when the west
slapped myriad sanctions on russia
that the country's economy would
collapse but a july forecast from the
international monetary fund shows that
despite of the sanctions the russian
economy is only expected to shrink by
six percent this year a big difference
from the double digit drop that some had
predicted earlier this spring
laura i would like to turn to you again
so there's been a fair bit of divergence
when it comes to analyses of how hard
sanctions have actually hit the russian
economy we've featured one prominent
yale study that says actually russia's
economy is on its knees while others say
the russian economy is proving really
resilient citing for example that
relatively strong ruble that we talked
about and those import export numbers
where do you fall along the spectrum
well clearly russian economy is doing
better than we expected six months ago
um
and that's uh i would i would credit the
skillful policy response especially by
the central bank
for for that result
and also the
somewhat more benign external
environment
than what we thought
but nevertheless uh that only means that
the economic decline this year
will be a bit
less than we thought
but on the other hand
the recession will continue into 2023
so all in all we're still talking about
a massive shock to the russian economy
and um
sort of uh ironical in this is that the
the
gdp decline this year
next year together must be of of a
similar magnitude that what we thought
in in the spring
but this whole russian recession
is of its own making
before the war broke out we forecasted
the gdp would grow at about two percent
and all the negative shocks ever since
have just been caused by russia's own
access
certainly self-inflicted harm there so
on the one hand a lot is depending on
western power still for russia's economy
to decline sufficiently as to make war
untenable on the other hand ukraine's
ability to stay solvent is dependent on
how much support and aid it's going to
get from its allies so one of the
ukrainian cities hit hardest by the
fallout of war is odessa many people
work in tourism but that has come to a
stand still there
many people need work and it's the
biggest problem
because it's not only war not only about
weapons and soldiers it's
also about resources and budgets so nick
as it is ukraine faces a monthly
shortfall of about five billion dollars
in public finances how do you assess the
ability of ukraine's allies to
accordingly adjust the aid they're
providing so that it corresponds with
what ukraine actually needs
well i mean if you look at the sums
actually in terms of the numbers they
are not huge by international standards
if you compare the sums discussed here
to the kind of sums that are now being
pumped into western european energy
systems to make you know to support uh
energy importers who are now having to
deal with increased gas price for
instance these are all pretty small
numbers but the issue is
timing so the ukrainians have been
complaining that time and time again
there have been meetings where various
western governments have made pledges to
support the ukrainian government budget
with either loans or just grants but
they're just not being transferred in a
timely manner so we've had a few
situations where you hear ukrainian
politicians saying it's two weeks till
we have to pay this that or the other
and the money just hasn't arrived from
the americans from whoever else so that
is a real issue getting the awareness in
western capitals for the kind of
timeliness of this
on the same scale as the kind of
awareness they have of the need for
weapons deliveries which we also know
has been a kind of endless story of the
ukrainians complaining that you know the
promises have been made but they're not
delivered on in anywhere near the kind
of speed that they need
so this is certainly a recurring theme
now we're seeing not enough
international financial aid going to
ukraine at the moment while especially
germany and its eu allies are only quite
slowly extricating themselves from their
trade relationship with russia so the
bank of russia recently reported some
figures that look at the difference in
value between exports and imports and
those show the country's current account
a surplus for the first seven months of
2022
surged to an all-time high of 166
billion dollars that's more than triple
the amount from a year ago oil and gas
revenues have soared while sanctions
have caused imports to plunge
to laura oil and natural gas prices
skyrocketed after the war began but in
the past prices eventually stabilized do
you think russia's economy will be hit
hard once prices do fall to levels seen
last year
uh
the first first thing to note probably
is that as the demand for russian oil
and coal have declined actually the
russian export prices
are currently
below the levels of january 2020
so for for from the point of view of
russia the the
ex commodity prices have already
stabilized back to where they were
before the war
and this
simply means
that the record high tax revenues will
decline already in july
the federal revenues from oil and gas
were down by twenty percent compared to
july last year
and
none the all the other
other budget revenues outside from the
oil and gas fell by nearly 30 year and
year
this simply means the the
sort of the months
and maybe years ahead
will be
much tighter for for the russian
fiscal policies and the government
really needs to
plan to how to finance the deficit
the
this year the the deficit will be
fairly manageable
but uh
going into next year
they will if if the current price is per
second
and export volumes draw pressure will
need a combination of cutting
expenditures and and resorting to
to non-standard means of financing the
the
the the deficit if it's going to
remain
closed
okay so at this stage i would like to
bring in final questions for the both of
you well it's the same one actually and
we started with hindsight so let's try
and get speculative for this one so the
war can drag on indefinitely and there's
already
a lot of talk about this being a war of
attrition should the war go on another
six months what will the state of the
ukrainian economy be
that's a certainly a big question um i
think the ukraine government is
increasingly aware of the fact that
right now they could you know win the
military battle at least you know in
terms of holding the the front lines
where they are now at the same time lose
the long-term future if they let too
many people leave the country if life in
ukraine becomes too difficult if it's
not a country where ukrainians see
themselves in a position to build lives
themselves build businesses to you know
create a future so i think it certainly
is a desire in ukraine now to try and
get back to some kind of normality at
least in the parts of the country
they're further away from the front
lines we've seen um ukraine very
successful in terms of digitalization um
you can basically have a digital
passport you can have all your
government services online and the
ukrainian government really interacting
with western tech giants there to bring
in investment to bring awareness for
ukraine and what it has to offer so i
think ukraine is going to be
pushing trying to make it a bigger part
of its national economy it's
a sector that you know wars can't
readily destroy or you know uh put an
end to you know in its ability to to
create jobs and create investment so i
think that's something that ukraine is
really going to be pushing in the hope
to make basically the you know at the
new war status quo kind of more
palatable to ordinary ukrainians who
kind of have to find a way of going
about their daily lives living their
family lives
you know developing career at the same
time as
basically preparing potentially to go
off and fight you know if the government
calls on them uh you know uh months and
weeks down the line
i mean we use the phrase new normal
during the coven pandemic a lot arguably
overused it but i think it applies again
this time around to ukrainians and the
war that they are experiencing
laura turning to you what is your answer
to this question another six months of
war where is russia's economy going to
be
going to be in in a more tight position
that it's now
but certainly um
certainly still
still fairly wealthy
it's the bit longer term view
that is is especially gloomy for russia
um i fully fully agree that sort of the
ukrainian government is currently doing
a lot in in
in trying to plan the rebuilding of the
country and and
and trying to take full benefit of
integration with the western
western countries and
restructuring
much of
the economy
to to become more based on whereas
russia is doing exactly the opposite
it's it's isolating itself from uh from
most of the world it's isolating itself
from the global
scientific community
and it's it's uh
sort of really trying to build a
domestic economy
that's only reliant on domestic
domestic innovation that a
few of the future in the longer term
looks much bleaker leaker for russia and
for ukraine in this sense
well nick at least ukrainians will be
able to take some hope from that
that's all for our business special
looking at ukraine and russia's
respective economies as the conflict
slips into its seventh month many thanks
to my guests nick connolly and lara
solanco if you've enjoyed this video
remember to hit like and subscribe and
why not check out some of our other
stuff on our dw news channel on youtube
from me and the team goodbye and we hope
to see you again soon